Die sonne birgt ein bisher noch nicht gelöstes rätsel und es ist bis zu 5,6 millionen grad celsius
während die sonnenoberfläche lediglich
5500 grad celsius heiß ist kommen die sonnenatmosphäre wie corona auf diese unglaubliche temperatur und niemand weiss warum
jetzt hat die nasa eine sonde deep akasol
apropos sonne geschickt um dieses rätsel endlich zu lösen vielen dank an unsere ersten mitglieder auf dem kanal die gestern für dieses thema gestimmt haben
klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Und ihr alle habt ja hier schon in der community abstimmung gezeigt dass astronomie
top thema ist und dieses thema hier ist mit sicherheit das spannendste was ich da im moment tut die sonne
wirkt nämlich ein geheimnis und das ist wirklich ziemlich rätselhaft entdeckt wurde ist vor knapp
150 jahren da konnte nämlich die korona der sonne zum ersten mal bei einer sonnenfinsternis
beobachtet werden der mond hatte sich zwischen erde und sonne geschoben dabei analysierten
forschungsdienst das spektrum des lichts und
stellten eine grüne spektrallinien fest die zu keinem bekannten element hier auf der erde passt sie nannten das unbekannte element
kolonie um weil es sie es bisher nur in der korona der sonne entdeckt hatten was für ein irrtum denn wer sich das periodensystem
ansieht wird feststellen dass es kein solches element gibt noch viele jahrzehnte hielt sich diese these bis zwei
astrophysiker das rätsel dieser spektrallinien lösten es handelt sich um eisen ionen also
eisenatome denen aber elektronen fehlen insgesamt fehlen ihnen 13 der 26
elektronen ein extrem seltener zustand der nur mit unmengen an energie
erreicht werden kann schnell wurde klar die korona muss heißer als eine million grad sein
doch das ist paradox wie kann es sein dass die sonne selbst nur
5500 grad heiß ist aber die atmosphäre
drumherum rund 2 bis 500 mal heisser
das ist so als würde man sich von der heizung entfernen und es würde immer heißer werden wie kann das sein
niemand weiß es genau es gibt theorien und vermutung aber
niemand ist sich wirklich sicher was da oben genau passiert deshalb schickt die nasa jetzt die packers solarprodukte sonne
und zwar so nah wie noch nie einen von menschen gebautes gefährt der sonne war mehr als
1400 grad muss die sonne dabei aushalten bis zu
6,2 millionen kilometer wird sie der sonne
dabei nahe kommen und damit durch die atmosphäre durch die korona der sonne fliegen geschützt wird sie dabei durch einen zwölf zentimeter dicken carbon panzer
mit diversen messinstrumenten ausgestattet
dringend die sonne so in bisher unbekannte sphären vor und wird tatsächlich für absolut
bahnbrechende erkenntnisse sorgen denn dort wo sie unterwegs sein wird war vorher noch nie
irgendein menschen gemacht das gerät und es ist eine absolut unerforscht region
zitat die packers oder pop wird geschichte schreiben aber sie hat auch das potenzial
das forschungsfeld der solaren physik in eine ganz neue richtung zu lenken das sagt einer der beteiligten forscher nur
rafi von applied physics laboratory der johns hopkins
university noch einmal vielen dank an unsere youtube mitglieder für ihre sensationelle unterstützung wir sind
überwältigt und freuen uns sehr
dass er bei dieser brandneuen möglichkeit dabei seid wenn ihr auch mitglied im team pixum werden wollt und monatlich ein weiteres exklusives
video und euren eigenen
privaten livestream nicht verpassen wollt dann klickt auf den button unter diesem video dort erfahrt ihr wie das funktioniert und welche vorteile
euch erwarten in den nächsten wochen werden wir das angebot noch etwas
erweitern ansonsten freuen wir uns natürlich auch wenn er uns als
unterstützung ein like oder einen kommentar da last oder das video an jemanden schickt der sich genauso für die spannende welt der astronomie interessiert wie
ihr
und wenn er kein video zum thema astronomie und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht denn die etwas
unzuverlässige abo box hier auf youtube und werdet sogar vorab über neue videos von mir informiert einfach hier
drauf kriegen und am besten auch meinen schwester cara klicks um social media abonnieren dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
genau glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken rätsel der sonne gelöst da geht es aber ein anderes geheimnis
das inzwischen gelüftet wurde bis dann
bleibt dran